Betsy is with us in Cedar Falls Iowa hi
Betsy how are you Oh Dave I'm so excited
decided to talk to you how can I help
so I first just wanted to start by
telling thank you because my husband and
I use Financial Peace University in the
envelope system starting last fall and
my husband is a main breadwinner for our
family so he's an engineer makes about
85,000 and I'm just finishing up school
I have about a year and a half left
so we pay for school out of pocket but
um here's what I wanted to thank you
today my husband lost his job and um but
we're not freaking out because our
finances are in control because of you
so I guess my questions are for you is
just like what should our immediate
financial priorities be know why did he
lose his job
his company I'm sorry his company's
downsizing and so they're making cuts
across the board any severance package
um he hasn't told me first and then four
weeks of severance after that he has all
right here's what first uh about a month
and a half so May 1st will be his last
day Oh many or week was for weeks okay
Wow okay and what kind of engineer is he
he's a chemical engineer chemical
engineer okay how long have been with
this company you spend with his company
he's not an engineer about a year and a
half when he leaves he'll have been with
his company for two years okay have you
all been in Cedar Falls a long time no
honestly we went to be University of
Iowa galaga um and we've lived here
about a year and a half fish okay so you
came there for the job yeah we came here
for the job and then I went to school up
here okay cool so he's what 28 no
actually we're really young he's only 25
and I'm 23
okay all right um the truth of the
matter is and it doesn't feel like this
today but let me tell you the way it
really is okay this is awesome it is
wonderful because he's leaving a job and
he's going to go make more money you're
in a fight a white-hot economy right now
people are hiring hand over fist in this
economy nobody's talking about it and
you're going to end up moving to a city
that you'd like better and make more
money and you wouldn't have done it if
they didn't fire him and basically if he
has a job that starts May the 2nd he
puts four weeks of severance in his
pocket as a signing bonus this is going
to turn out to be a blessing you're
going to make more money a year and
you're going to put four weeks in your
pocket okay that's how it's going to
work that's how it's going to work as
long as he doesn't sit on his butt now
and so his full-time job between now and
May is get a job that starts my second
in a city you all like you own your home
yeah okay so you got to get that up for
sale if he takes a job out of City and
so you got to get that sold but again
you're in a good economy to sell a house
this is a great time for all this to
happen thank God it didn't happen three
years ago you'd be up a creek this is
awesomeness I'm serious sure he's going
to make a hundred thousand dollars a
year and you're going to be in a city
you like better and you're going you're
going to put four weeks in your pocket
you mark my words you call me back in
August and tell me if I'm a liar I trust
you because we've seen you know we have
seen what following your plans work you
call ultimately God's plan has done yeah
now he's going to get you gonna have to
hustle and grind to get the job okay
okay but today starting starting this
morning listen you get 24 hours to
grieve and whine and suck your thumb a
little bit and then after 24 hours he's
got to get after it and go get a job
okay turn over every rock talk to
everybody he knows by phone don't be
leaving emails and don't be filling out
blank job applications on blank websites
nobody reads that crap and filling out a
bunch of stuff on career websites you're
going to waste
time with that go find people he knows
in the business that he worked with
before that worked with him at the other
place and find out where some of the
other guys that are getting laid off
where they're landing and just get out
there and shake and rattle and roll and
hustle and grind and I he got all the
way told me he's going to have a job if
he gets after it okay you got turnover
rocks right mm-hmm but if he'll do that
and just just be very professional about
his job hunt um for this next move I
predict an increase in pay a city you
like better and four weeks of severance
in your pocket that's my prediction okay
here's the other thing here's the thing
you're not broke you're right you're not
desperate and you know broke people
interviewed desperate people interview
different to people that aren't
desperate you sit in the chair different
their vocal cords aren't as tight
they're they answer questions more
cleanly because their mind is not
working because they're not sitting
there thinking oh I hope they hire me
hope they hire me hope to hire me
they're sitting there thinking I wonder
if I really want to work here
it turns the tables on the interviewer
and it's just the best place to be you
guys are in the driver's seat all the
way around on this thing so good times
good time I'm going to send you a copy I
don't have Kelly pick up on send you a
copy of Dan Miller's book 48 days to the
work you love follow that process in
that book on how to get a job and then
you call me back in August and tell me
if I'm a liar because I'm not this is
going to work this is awesome this is
great news hey thanks for the call hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]